tommy à votre crâne merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur arte france
bonjour quatre à six semaines à tenir
avant un allègement des restrictions
sanitaires sur la sémantique amedi
d'emmanuel mapfre ont tout à l'heure
est-ce que vous pouvez encore tenir
on n'a pas vraiment le choix ça fait un
an qu'on tient cette maman que la
culture souffre finalement et celles qui
souffrent le plus un de ces restrictions
liées à la crise sanitaire
on perd des artistes on perd des
vocations
la france a une richesse culturelle
incroyable est en train de disparaître
donc espérons qu effectivement cette
échéance fixée par le président de la
république pour la bonne et que l'on
puisse envisager à partir de la mi-avril
d'une reprise des activités culturelles
que ce soit le spectacle cinéma théâtre
et dé tous y fait vivre
finalement les français et qui nous sort
de notre quotidien très dure vie de
maintenant un an puisque pour rappel
c919 les billets 2020 les premières
descriptions ont pas paru et que les
cultures a commencé progressivement à se
confiner sans vraiment être né depuis
maintenant près de vingt douze mois pile
est donc cette lettre
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pensez que
cette lettre ouverte fera entendre vos
revendications alors que l'épidémie de
kobe de 19 flambe en france
qu'est ce que vous en attendez
exactement ce qu'on attend finalement
c'est une prise en compte réelle
problématique
au-delà des aides fournies puisque la
culture c'est pas une industrie pour
vous mettre sous perfusion et on est
tous contents une allemande le 6 mai on
venait à décider pas mais les gens ont
besoin de travailler aujourd'hui donc ce
qu'on attend c'est vraiment une reprise
d'activité c'est un calendrier
ces sont des annonces sport de la part
des ministères et une perspective de
remise au travail de notre industrie
au delà de z qui peuvent être données
pour rappel et là on est quand même sur
1,3 million d'emplois qui sont menacés
c'est énorme
l'évocation surtout
jonah hill sont la jeunesse est
fortement touchée par cette crise
cette fois le public ou aussi les jeunes
à mon besoin de reprendre le travail et
on a besoin comme l'a fait l'angleterre
d'un calendrier
derrière en phase avec les objectifs de
vaccination en phase avec les sanitaires
qui sont à l'étude pour vous donner des
perspectives et l ouverture et de
reprise d'activité
le lendemain le dow aussi vous citez
dans votre lettre ouverte au président
emmanuel macron des pays européens qui
ont rouvert des lieux culturels vous
pensez à quel pays l'espagne ou l'italie
par exemple qu'est ce qui leur permet de
l'ouvrir contrairement à la france
on pense à l'espagne et à l'italie on
pense aux annonces qui sont faites aux
pays bas où et qui sont faites en grande
bretagne si permis au pays de rouvrir
c'est l'application du protocole
sanitaire encore il ya quinze jours
une étude allemande publiée il trouve
qui démontre scientifiquement que un
théâtre un cinéma un musée avec des
normes sanitaires des poteaux paul bien
appliqués sont moins dangereux
l'école un bureau les transports en
commun ou un centre commercial
donc il ya une inégalité de traitement
entre la culture et les autres ebit est
essentielle et nous qu'on souhaite c'est
que un équilibre pouvoir établi que tout
le monde
l'ensemble de notre pays et se projeter
dans une reprise d'activité
puisqu'aujourd'hui on n'a aucune donnée
city qui vient prouver la théâtre un
cinéma
aucune fête soit dangereuse puisque
toutes ces activités sont à l'arrêt
maintenant on a passé finalement deux
promesses puisque on fait beaucoup de
promesses ou souhaite c'est de l'action
c'est du concret et tous les
professionnels pareils sur des
protocoles pour leur filière hans être
prêts sont des professionnels
responsables savent accueillant le
public et donc on pense aujourd'hui il
pas un agenda clair d engagement fort de
la part de l'état qui courent au delà
des fonds apportés et qui vont vers une
totale et culturels
le mois de juin vous parlez de protocole
sanitaire
c'est à dire vous avez beaucoup de
choses qui sont à l'étude en fonction
des activités si vous voulez parce que
chaque activité culturelle sbc dans les
cinémas dans les théâtres au mois de
septembre
par exemple il y avait des protocoles
qui était appliqué ainsi un siège sur
deux entre le port du mas était pour les
et pour le spectacle vivant vous pensent
à notamment la présentation de tests au
moins 2 soit un peu moins de façon deux
roues de moins de 48 heures comme c'est
le cas avec n'ont pas voyagé mais ces
choses sont peu produits existantes sont
à l'étude
voire même en test dans certains pays
notamment en grande bretagne et on pense
qu'on a bien des moyens tant humains de
mettre en oeuvre ces expérimentations
puis d'appliquer ces protocoles pour
faire en sorte les activités avec leurs
spécificités d'accueil du public puisse
reprendre dans les conditions qui
permettent d'offrir une sécurité
maximale pour le public pour les
personnes travaillent dans ces lieux
culturels
vous n'êtes d'utiliser le terme
expérimentation justement c'est que la
ministre de la culture à roselyne
bachelot souhaite des concerts des
spectacles test d'expérimentation pour
voir justement la diffusion d'une phrase
comme de du coronavirus parmi les
spectateurs
comment est-ce que vous accueillez 7
s'est annoncée selon vous est-ce que ça
va se faire quand où comment alain on
accueille bien ces annonces puisque on a
besoin de prouver scientifiquement la
portée d'un virus dans un concert et là
on parle de frontières en intérieur on
est très contents que quelque chose se
passe simplement s'il faut savoir c'est
que l'été dernier déjà il y avait déjà
des événements qui se sont tenues en
extérieur notamment parce que la charge
virale est assez démontré
scientifiquement est beaucoup moins
forte en extérieur dont les concerts qui
vont se tenir vont permettre de soutenir
l'ouverture des boîtes de nuit et club
des salles de concerts en yeux fermés
nous ce qu'on souhaite aussi fait des
engagements
or pour que le plus tôt possible les
activités en extérieur il se reprendre
et pas avec des personnes assises sur
une chaise parce que ça pour une
justement roselyne bachelot a parlé de
cela par rapport aux festivals cet été
avec des jauges de 5000 personnes pour
les festivals assis avec avec un
espacement entre entre les spectateurs
vous qui êtes dans le monde de la
musique électronique est ce que c'est
faisable on sait par exemple les
organisateurs du festival du duel festin
du côté de de clisson vers un vers
nantes
gic type hard rock métal disent on ne va
pas pouvoir tenir avec avec des
conditions comme celles-ci
non mais il ya énormément de
l'esthétique pour lesquels c'était
impossible et musique ils ont mis le hip
hop donc aidé le métal ont fait toutes
les musiques écoutées par les jeunes
et encore une fois ce qui nous inquiète
un c'est cette politique de dire qu'on
va permettre des choses dans un certain
cadre
et encore on va on va sacrifier la
jeunesse c'est comme quand on parle peu
passant vaccinale otage un jeune de 20
ans tu as l'équipe de se faire vacciner
en tongs et 2022
on appelait 2022 si on conditionne
lampley un événement réel un pape saint
sava dire que les jeunes pourquoi toute
l'année 2000 29 en devoir rester chez
eux
donc c'est la double peine systématique
ou quand datent d esprit musical
nous condamnons j'ai toute une
génération de 20,35 même 40 ans qui va
encore souffrir finalement de ces
mesures dont on espère qu'il va y avoir
une réflexion intelligente peut être
fait en sorte que tout le monde puisse
reparle a fait cet été on est prêt à
réduire les jauges effet à contrôler les
élus elle est publique et des tests mais
il faut que ces choses là ce qui se
passe dans les conditions réalistes par
rapport aux esthétiques musicales où se
retrouvent pas effectivement à devoir et
kras s'embarquant restauration quand
vous êtes un geek festival c'est 8h10
heure vous pouvez pas accueillant sans
lui donner à boire et bien manger ne pas
demander à quelqu'un de rester assis sur
sa chaise pendant huit heures et musique
qui est juste pas vous aussi merci
tommy votre crâne d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
artiste président de technopol est
signataire donc de cette lettre ouverte
à emmanuel macron intitulé je cite des
confits non la culture